to understand more about the right machine operation. I use a weighted blanket. Does the
light need to have direct, straight direct contact with me? Or is it okay if the weighted blanket
is between me and the light? So I believe that the frequencies are still going to go through the
blanket, but the more things that the frequencies have to go through, the less benefit that a person's
going to have. But understand in saying that, what benefit do you need from the right machine?
You need the frequencies to hit and penetrate your body. So, can we, the frequencies hit and penetrate
my body and penetrate and have the same effect on my cancer cells? If I have a direct
not impeded access to my body. Well, there is a balance that you have to kind of go through there
because we're going to use a machine that has more voltage, more amperage. And it's going to
penetrate my body and penetrate the bed and penetrate the floor and go underneath the floor to the
bedroom in the basement. That's kind of overkill, right? So I just need it to affect me. And that's
my whole purpose with that. However, it's difficult to measure, it's impossible to measure,
you know, with everything it's going through, just through your skin and through your fat layers and
through your muscle layers and through your bone, the direct effect on the cancer itself. I always think
you're better off airing and having the bulb as close to you as possible.
There is a law in physics that every, you know, I think it's every, I don't know, every foot that
it's away, you're going to have the energy that's going, that you're going to hit something like that.
I don't remember the law. But so the more things you're going through, you're going to filter some of
that energy that's hitting your body as well. So I always think that the closer it is to your body,
in the more direct you have that light to your body, the better off it's going to be.
Now that being said, there's times that you're running different frequencies that it can,
it can take a lot on you because it is really hitting you hard and having a big physiological effect
on your body. And there's times that you may feel like you want to set the bulb a little bit farther
away because you're possibly almost getting like a hoaxive or type reaction because you may be
killing cells or killing bacteria and things. Certainly with diseases like live disease where you're
killing gram negative bacteria, that is very commonly seen. And I have to tell those people to
actually put the bulb under the bed because we do want some filtration of those frequencies so that
we don't kill gram negative bacteria to quickly and liberate lipopolysaccharides. So
it's pretty hard to argue that it's not having an effect. I think when you're trying to kill cancer,
you want it as close to you as possible. That's just my understanding that that's how I've always
recommended it's yours.